there's been a myth in the marketplace
for 10-15 years that there's a crime
going on that's very difficult to
understand it's our king you have to
know a lot of jargon to even understand
it but it's as if the savings of America
are in a big fish tank and some people
have figured out how to open a spigot
and just drain it out and nobody up on
top can really see that this is
happening
well it sounds lunatic and I didn't
believe it I heard it you know some
version of that's been floating around
the market since the early nineties
didn't pay any attention so people
started getting in touch with me about
three years ago and asked me to talk to
me about it and that telling me to look
into and stuff and I was saying now I
dismissed them all and what eventually
happened is one guy got through and I
put him on the speakerphone as I was
backing up a suitcase I'll never forget
and he described this very arcane thing
for about into 45 minutes and at the end
of it I was saying fine buddy I
understand and thanks a lot and he could
tell I was give him the brush-off and he
said look I can tell you're giving me
the brush-off so I'm gonna make a series
of predictions and when these come true
you call me and the predictions are
here's a set of five journalists that
are going to call you and they're going
to call you and do hatchet jobs on you
none of them had ever called me before
secondly so you're gonna get these these
calls Patrick you're going to find
yourself the target of a federal
investigation you're gonna find yourself
trading on some foreign exchanges that
you never heard of that
you know Bahamas and Australian stuff
and forth the SEC is going to start
publishing a list of companies that are
seeing a certain oddity occur in their
stock it's called the regulation show
threshold list and when they start
publishing that in a couple months
there's only half of 1% of companies are
going to be on it but you're gonna be on
it I said okay buddy okay thanks hung up
well over the next eight weeks every one
of those stories came true in fact on
that trip that I was packing for it the
journalist started calling me well that
was odd and you know the power of any
journalist called me we became the
object of an FTC investigation that was
sort of
a very flimsy investigation that went
nowhere and they dropped it
we started trading on exchanges in
Stuttgart a very immune ik you know
Bahamas out having nothing to do with
that and when this list came out of and
there were only 30 or 40 companies out
of 7,000 the list came up we were on the
list well the power of any theory is its
ability to make predictions and if
someone could make that set of
predictions you got to look into it so I
started looking into it I spent about
three months and buried in it and I
gradually realized the guy was right
there is this crack in the financial
system and the savings of Americans are
being drained out of that crack there's
one economist who says excuse me I mean
a serious economist who says it may be
tens of millions maybe hundreds of
billions of dollars have been stolen
through this crack now what is the crack
a normal stock trade is you're buying
stock for me you give me money and I'll
give you stock that's called settlement
believe it or not there's a loophole
that exists in the system and when the
time comes for me to give you the stock
that you bought from me I can give you
just a I owe you basically for some
stock now you or I could do this but big
hedge funds and front brokers have ways
of doing this and all the really giving
is in are you and you never know that
you get your brokerage statement from
Merrill Lynch or Morgan Stanley and it
says you got the stock well no stock
ever came all you got was on are you
it happens happens only about one or two
percent of the time and the and the
loophole was probably created for some
good reasons that you want if somebody
signs the wrong piece of paper or
somebody's dog eats their certificate
you want them to be able to say yeah you
don't want the system to freeze but what
happened and you know what seems to
happen to some hedge funds have figured
out how to manipulate this loophole and
inject hundreds of millions or even
billions of these what are in fact fake
shares into the market now
it creates three effects three problems
a small medium and a large problem small
problem is it's ruined corporate
democracy and there was an article by
Bob Drummond in Bloomberg Markets
magazine mid last year
that's called the corporate voting
charade well he has people on the record
in the back offices of Wall Street the
transfer agents who actually count votes
that say with quotes like this is
positively criminal wait we regularly do
not have any idea who's entitled to vote
and who isn't we regularly get two to
three times as many votes as there are
shares now as crazy as all that sounds
the New York Stock Exchange did a study
on 341 elections found over voting in
all three hundred and forty-one why this
is a problem is afterworld common Enron
and such the American government
solution was to these corporate scandals
of the early 2000 2001 2002 it was to
tighten up corporate governance or
corporate governance inning boards of
directors that's based on corporate
elections which is built demonstrable on
quicksand the whole system is broken and
you can look this article up and it's
even the SEC just two Tuesday's ago came
out and basically said fixing this
problem was going to be our work in 2008
they had a market regulation Eric Surrey
said that so that's the small problem
everything I just described as the small
problem it's a complete hoax corporate
democracy is now a hoax because of this
over voting problem if you have to if
you have all these fake shares in the
system and people voting the fake shares
and they all come in there aren't really
believing are there aren't even any
rules in it on which votes get thrown
out and which don't so the whole that
whole system is our sherrod and that's
the smallest of the three problems the
mid-size problem is you can destroy
companies using this technique if you if
it just really hasn't happened by random
human human error you'd see these these
fake shares these phantom shares
scattered around the market like like
peanut butter spread over sandwich
they'd be spread evenly well yes you see
hired an economist named Leslie bonny to
study this and she came she did the
statistical analysis and saw where
they're concentrated and she says no way
this is happening by random human error
this is it's it's it's massive it's
endemic in the system and it's clearly
being used to manipulate it's clearly
being targeted and how it is tart how
it's used to manipulate is you after a
small company a small cap meaning 300
million
million or less you pick up biotech or a
financial company or just a technology
company where it's easy to create a lot
of misdirection and smoke and mirrors
about you couldn't do what I'm about to
describe you couldn't do to IBM or
Microsoft we can do it as small
companies and you just flood the market
with fake shares in their companies and
you can crack the market and if you can
do this while you have a couple of your
shield journalists just write stories
after stories banging the company you
can basically drop it to nothing and if
it's a company like a biotech the bio
tech model in America has always been
you know angel funding small venture
rounds couple venture rounds goes public
and then it's sips at the capital
markets for 5 10 15 years as it develops
drugs well you can you can snap that
lifecycle dry the company will collapse
and you can walk out with its market cap
and maybe you can mark out with that
walk out with that market cap two or
three times over so is that going on
well three years ago the SEC was saying
this is a myth this isn't a myth they
finally faced enough public pressure
that they had to they did they passed a
very tepid regulation regulation show
and it it said that they were going to
start disclosing the names of companies
that see that are seeing excessive
numbers of these these phantom shares
and their stock and they actually said
on their website the SEC website
actually said we have to grandfather
that is we have to forgive all the
Phantom shares that are already in the
system because we're afraid of the
volatility that might result from large
pre-existing open positions now that's
bizarre because a month or a year
earlier they'd been saying there are no
this isn't going on it's a myth it's
myth its salt wacky and then they came
out and said well okay we're gonna try
to do something about it but we have to
forgive all that's in the system because
if we don't it's gonna crack the system
geez I've been down this rabbit hole so
long it's hard for me to tell what
normal people seem do you see why that's
contradictory